hace 5 años que los rodillas de mianmar
huyeron a bangladesh el programa de
educación que propone recientemente
unicef hace crecer la esperanza de los
jóvenes refugiados yo no tengo el
certificado de estudios durante mi
estancia en este campo como demostrar
que fui a la escuela si vuelvo a mianmar
la semana pasada la onu explicó que al
regreso de la minoría musulmana a
mianmar era todavía incierto pero su
repatriación es el objetivo para
bangladesh que debe enfrentar la
creciente inseguridad en los campos del
sureste del país en daca la situación de
los jóvenes refugiados ruin jazz es
particularmente preocupante
los jóvenes refugiados pueden ser
explotados a cualquier edad y crecer en
un campo privado de educación sin
ninguna esperanza y sin sueños en que
monstruos se pueden convertir no lo
sabemos
este joven ruin ya espera continuar sus
estudios para volver algún día a su país
y convertirse en ingeniero aeronáutico
pero cinco años después de la crisis sus
esperanzas son frágiles